et notre invité politique ce matin s'est
Stanislas Guérini bonjour bonjour C'est
beaucoup d'être avec nous ministre de la
transformation et de la fonction
publique on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Christelle Bertrand du
groupe La Dépêche bonjour Christelle
bonjour Yann bonjour Stéphane
vous avez annoncé des mesures salariales
pour les fonctionnaires augmentation
générale de 1,5% au premier juillet des
primes pour les bas et les moyens
salaires mais pour les syndicats le
compte n'y est pas sa ne répond pas à
l'urgence salariale dans la fonction
publique du style est-ce que vous
entendez leur déception
j'entends et non seulement je les
entends mais je les réunis pour pouvoir
échanger avec eux évidemment je l'avais
fait il y a quelques semaines pour les
écouter pour écouter leur revendications
je les ai réunis à nouveau lundi pour
effectivement porter des annonces qui
sont des annonces tout à fait
significatives je veux le préciser vous
rappelez que l'année dernière on avait
augmenté le point d'indice 3 et demi
pour cent c'était la plus forte
augmentation du point d'indice depuis 37
ans
ce que j'ai annoncé au syndicat cette
semaine c'est que nous allions réitérer
le même effort la même enveloppe
budgétaire la même enveloppe salariale
sur cette fin d'année 3,5 milliards sur
le deuxième semestre 6 milliards d'euros
en année pleine l'année prochaine mais
j'assume de faire différemment ce que
nous allons faire l'année dernière parce
que quelle est la situation on a une
inflation qui est en train de décélérer
au global mais qui reste très forte sur
des produits alimentaires et qui
touchent en particulier les basses
salaires les classes moyennes ceux qui
sont au début des échelles de
rémunération et qui en plus parce que le
SMIC a augmenté voit souvent un manque
de progressivité dans leur carrière
c'est un phénomène maintes fois commenté
à votre rentable et donc les mesures
cette enveloppe budgétaire que je décris
là elle a les consacrée sera consacrée
spécifiquement à ça a augmenté de 2,5%
la rémunération indienne 2,5% c'est le
fixe des fonctionnaires en deux fois
1,5% de valeur du point des juillet
des distributions de points pour
l'ensemble de la grille en janvier 2024
auquel j'ajoute c'est plus rarement
mentionné des distributions de points
spécifiques des juillet aussi justement
au catégories C au début des catégories
B pour offrir une progressivité et
auquel j'ajoute une prime une prime
pouvoir d'achat et une prime Macron dans
le privé il y aura une prime pouvoir
d'achat pour les agents du public que je
concentre sur la première moitié des
fonctionnaires de 800 euros brut à 300
euros brut quand on est à 3250
pour automatiquement les agents de
l'État et les hôpitaux les Hospitaliers
à la main des collectivités
territoriales je précise parce que c'est
ce qu'elles nous ont demandé aussi
d'avoir des outils qui soient le moins
contraignants possible quand on touche à
la valeur indiciaire c'est les trois
versants automatiquement les outils
indemnitaires les primes c'est
effectivement davantage à la main pour
laisser de la marge de manœuvre aux
employeurs territoriaux
après les tensions créées par par la
réforme des retraites est-ce que ces
discussions n'aggravent pas encore un
petit peu les tensions avec les
organisations syndicales et cette
déception vraiment sincèrement je crois
pas sincèrement je crois pas quand on
s'est vu avec les syndicats on a convenu
c'était il y a quelques semaines de
donner la priorité à trois sujets
apporter des réponses à la question du
pouvoir d'achat
aller au bout de la négociation sur
l'instauration d'une prévoyance pour les
agents publics c'est un chantier majeur
Majeur qui est très souvent sous-estimé
il s'agit de la protection de la santé
des agents des questions d'invalidité
d'incapacité d'arrêt long maladie c'est
très important je souhaite boucler cette
négociation avant la mi-juillet avec les
syndicats et puis le troisième sujet
c'est de définir un accord de méthode
pour porter une réforme structurelle sur
la question des carrières sur la
question des parcours sur la question
des rémunérations et j'ai dit au
syndicat que j'étais prêt à mettre dans
des objets de négociation les éléments
de politique salariale comment est-ce
que on discute des rémunérations de
façon récurrente année après année avec
les syndicats de la fonction publique
avec l'ensemble des employeurs
territoires
le plus clair possible je pense que
c'est ça la clarté des débats le respect
aussi des interlocuteurs j'ai pas mis à
la négociation ce que je viens de vous
annoncer là je les ai écoutés on a eu
bilatérale je leur ai fait des annonces
je les porte pas à les négociation mais
en revanche pouvoir effectivement mettre
à plat la façon dont on discute des
rémunérations les éléments de politique
salariale puisque on souhaite
ça aboutir à quelque chose c'est à dire
ou qui porte sur l'année 2023 mais
effectivement pour mais pour de 24 il
peut y avoir d'autres augmentations une
réforme de structure sur les
rémunérations pour mettre à plat au fond
les questions de rémunération dans la
fonction publique avec quelques
priorités moi je considère et je les
mets sur la table que les priorités
c'est plutôt de protéger les agents qui
voient leur pouvoir d'achat vraiment
impacter rogné par l'inflation quand il
y a une inflation forte les priorités
c'est de pouvoir apporter des
perspectives d'évolution de carrière
parfois plus dynamique c'est ça souvent
qui manque dans nos politiques salariale
ça veut peut-être dire aussi pouvoir
davantage différencier les évolutions de
carrière et puis la troisième priorité à
mon sens pour les discussions
structurelles qu'on doit avoir
c'est de poser la question la
rémunération de la performance
individuelle et collective de
l'engagement des agents je crois que
tout ça c'est compatible donc une
rémunération mérite pour le dire plus
clairement ça existe déjà ce sont des
outils qui sont assez timides et
timidement utilisés parfois dans la
fonction publique je crois par exemple à
des plans d'intéressement c'est les
outils qui fonctionnent très bien qui
permettent de récompenser la performance
collective ça peut être par exemple
l'atteinte de nos ambitions sur la
transition écologique pourquoi pas on
peut rendre tout ceci compatible avec
les grandes transitions qu'on a opérées
individuel ce sont des discussions
structurelles qui restructureront
beaucoup peut-être la façon de rémunérer
les agents publics et cette discussion
là cette discussion là je veux la voir
avec les syndicats
employé donc moi ce que je dis est-ce
que vous dites il faut renforcer ça moi
je veux que le travail paye
je veux que dans la fonction publique
l'engagement les agents que je vois
toute la journée se décarcassaient
vraiment on l'a vu pendant les crises
mais on le voit à chaque instant ce sont
eux qui tiennent les services publics je
veux que ce travail-là paye soit
récompensé et ça peut être de façon
individuelle et ça peut être de façon
collective c'est ma philosophie vous
savez je la mets sur la table
aujourd'hui et je souhaite la porter à
négociation avec des organisations
syndicales vous avez déjà un rendez-vous
pris sur ce sujet là avec les
organisations syndicales j'ai indiqué
c'était nos échanges lundi avec la
multilatérale qu'on a tenu toutes les
organisations syndicales j'ai indiqué
que ces discussions de méthodes la
définition de cet objet de négociation
qui peut inclure la politique salariale
j'étais prêt à tenir avant l'été pour
avancer sur ces questions là donc ça
nous fait du travail avant la coupure
estivale mais enfin je crois que si à la
fois on a apporté des réponses je crois
puissante je l'ai démontré sur la
question du pouvoir d'achat peut-être
c'est pas suffisant au titre de syndicat
mais ils ont quand même saluer les
mesures les outils peut-être qu'ils
auraient souhaité plus si on a avancé
sur ces questions de pouvoir d'achat de
prévoyance qu'on a remis en route d'une
certaine façon le chantier structurel
qu'on a défini un accord de méthode je
crois qu'on aura fait pour les
fonctionnaires pour les agents publics
œuvres utile c'est tout ce qui
m'intéresse l'augmentation et le
concerne également les fonctionnaires
publics territoriaux les élus locaux ils
comprennent certes la nécessité
d'augmenter les fonctionnaires mais ils
disent aussi que c'est une charge pour
leur budget et qu'ils ont été mis devant
le fait accompli c'est ce que dit
l'Association des maires de France
qu'est-ce que vous lui répondez d'abord
il y a deux questions est-ce qu'on a
concerté la réponse est oui
j'ai réuni le 23 mai dernier l'ensemble
des associations d'élus je les ai
réunies à nouveau à vendre rencontrer
les organisations syndicales donc c'est
pas vrai de dire qu'il y a pas eu de
concertation c'est vrai que j'ai pris
mes responsabilités j'ai annoncé des
choses mais en ayant entendu les
empereurs territoriaux est-ce qu'on a
écouté les messages qui nous ont passés
là aussi la réponse c'est oui ils ont
des trois choses ils ont même dit
publiquement dans la presse prêt à des
hausse de rémunération mais modérée
concentrer les efforts sur les bas
salaires et lisser l'effort dans le
temps précisément c'est ce que nous
avons essayé de faire ce qu'on vient
qu'il y a un équilibre à trouver vous
m'avez interrogé sur les attentes des
syndicats m'interroger à présent sur les
attentes des ampleurs territoriaux mais
nous avons répondu à ces attentes là pas
que du point d'indice 1,5 % tout de
suite là où c'était 3,5 l'année dernière
concentré nos efforts sur les salaires
je viens de vous le démontrer c'est
précisément ce que nous faisons mais
une partie en 2023 une partie en 2024
donc avec plus de visibilité c'est là
aussi ce que nous ont et les employeurs
reconnaissent d'ailleurs qu'il y a eu
cette écoute là mais je comprends bien
que ça induit des efforts contraints
dans les budgets enfin quand même est-ce
que vous êtes seul question
supplémentaires avant de répondre à
cette question là il faut quand même
presser la seule question qui vaille
c'est si les employeurs territoriaux les
élus locaux avaient été seules
décisionnaires
[Musique]
mais je considère qu'investir sur les
agents publics au moment où l'inflation
grignote le pouvoir d'achat il faut être
très clair aujourd'hui il y a un agent
public sur cinq rémunéré au niveau du
SMIC parce que le SMIC a beaucoup
augmenté ça nécessite des réponses mais
moi je crois qu'elles sont plutôt de
l'ordre de l'investissement quand on
paye mieux nos fonctionnaires ça veut
pas dire qu'on va s'exonérer de le
transformation de nos politiques
publiques il y a pas des économies
chaque jour moi j'ai toujours considéré
que il fallait pas découper les sujets
on va pas dire il y a un sujet salarial
2023 et donc on va avoir le débat
spécifique pour savoir comment on
compare ce sujet là et puis tout à
l'heure on parlera les secrétaires de
mairie avec les sénateurs et puis il y a
des coûts d'énergie et puis il y a
d'autres charges qui peuvent être
adultes je crois qu'il faut un débat
global sur la question du financement
des collectivités et je le dis en tant
que ministre d'un gouvernement
qui a plutôt pas de leçon à recevoir des
gouvernements précédents sur les
questions de dotation générale aux
collectivités on en a inversé la
trajectoire on a plutôt augmenté donc ce
débat il va avoir lieu précisément les
associations d'élus elles sont reçues à
Bercy cette semaine pour préparer les
astuces des finances publiques elle se
tiendront la semaine prochaine qui doit
permettre d'avoir à la fois une vision
globale sur tous les sujets les dépenses
les recettes l'ensemble des dépenses et
l'ensemble des recettes et puis donner
une vision avec une visibilité dans le
temps moi quand j'échange d'ailleurs
encore avec François Sauvadet président
des départements de France ce que
souhaitent les associations d'élus c'est
d'avoir des perspectives d'évolution de
pouvoir se projeter dans le temps et se
débat là il est absolument primordial
pour notre pays alors ni en début
d'année à Nantes vous avez aussi
souhaité d'autres ouvrir d'autres
chantiers concernant la fonction
publique et notamment ouvrir le chantier
des parcours des fonctionnaires où
est-ce qu'on en est
précisément ce sont les sujets que je
mets à discussion avec les organisations
syndicales là maintenant tout de suite
avec quel axe de travail faire en sorte
qu'on puisse évoluer plus rapidement
dans la fonction publique ça ça sera mon
fil rouge la question des compétences
que le fait d'acquérir des compétences
par la prise de responsabilité par son
travail ou par la formation ça soit
mieux valorisé dans les parcours de
carrière ça permette de changer de
métier éventuellement je signale au
passage qu'on a pris des mesures vous
voyez que j'évite pas le débat sur les
retraites on nous dit parfois qu'on veut
plus jamais en parler qu'on apprend des
mesures dans le texte retraite pour
pouvoir justement faciliter les
changements de métier dans la fonction
publique ne pas perdre des droits quand
on devient par exemple policier quand on
était surveillant on pénitentiaire pour
prendre un seul exemple donc tout ça
c'est ce qu'il nous faut travailler
notamment le chantier faire la
possibilité de supprimer les catégories
ABC est-ce que c'est toujours en
réflexion moi je crois que il faut
garder un système de catégorie
d'ailleurs quand vous regardez toutes
les grandes organisations il y a
toujours des catégories vous prenez une
convention collective il y a des
catégories ce qui pose parfois problème
dans la fonction publique c'est que la
façon dont on est entré dans la fonction
publique fonction d'un grade bien fait
en sorte qu'on est parfois coincé et qui
a une forme de plafond de verre prenons
un exemple très concret puisque ça sera
les débats que nous aurons avec les
sénateurs cet après-midi secrétaire de
mairie on est recruté parfois c'est le
cas le plus souvent en catégorie C et
pour pouvoir franchir la catégorie
suivante alors il faut pendant de longs
mois préparer un concours administratif
parfois concours qui sont avec un
rapport un peu éloigné avec la réalité
du métier du côté et donc
effectivement c'est de pouvoir faciliter
le passage les mobilités que l'étiquette
qu'on a sur le front parfois on puisse
la décoller un peu plus facilement par
son travail par ses compétences ou par
la formation et c'est précisément ce que
nous allons faire je prends cet exemple
des secrétaires de mes rêves mais parce
qu'il me semble très bon parce que ce
métier il symbolise au fond les
difficultés d'attractivité qu'on a dans
la fonction publique et démographie
recruter en catégorie B les secrétaires
de je veux faire les deux je veux faire
en sorte que ce métier c'est plutôt un
métier de catégorie B donc on puisse à
terme plus facilement recruter en
catégorie B mais je veux surtout
permettre les promotions vous voyez je
veux pas être trop technique là mais
souvent les employeurs territoriaux
disent nous c'est très rigide la façon
de faire les promotions on a des quotas
de promotion qui nous donnent tout un
tas de contraintes et bien ce qui est
proposé dans cette loi là qui est très
importante c'est de pouvoir justement
déroger au quotas de promotion donner
beaucoup de souplesse aux employeurs
territoriaux selon deux mécanismes soit
en reconnaissant les compétences des
secrétaires c'est une forme de
Validation des Acquis de l'Expérience
c'était trop peu existant à la fonction
publique c'est ça qu'il faut qu'on
développe soit parce qu'elles font une
formation de qualification et donc par
le temps passé de catégorie celle
pourront passer à catégorie B beaucoup
plus facilement on donne de la souplesse
on donne des marges de manœuvre aux
employeurs territoriaux c'est la
philosophie de travail qui est la mienne
pour l'ensemble de la réforme alors en
pleine crise du logement il y a aussi un
sujet majeur pour les fonctionnaires
c'est les difficult pour se loger vous
avez souhaité que certains soient
prioritaires ou est-ce qu'on en est
aussi de ce chantier là bien nous allons
tenir dans quelques jours ça sera d'ici
la fin du mois de juin un comité
interministériel du logement des
fonctionnaires justement pour pouvoir
mobiliser toutes les forces pour
apporter des réponses parce que je crois
que la question du logement des
fonctionnaires elle est clé à la fois
pour des enjeux de pouvoir d'achat aussi
de qualité de vie tout simplement ce
sont dans la beaucoup parlé pendant la
crise sanitaire des travailleurs de
première ligne qui sont parfois pardon
pour les enfants à l'autre bout de la
ligne de RER et donc je souhaite qu'on
puisse aller soignants par exemple les
personnages qui comprennent leur lieu de
travail d'évidence et c'est une réponse
aussi aux questions d'attractivité je
veux pas avoir je vais vous dire je vais
pas laisser penser que j'ai une baguette
magique tout ça dépend évidemment de
l'offre de logement et donc c'est un
chantier qui doit s'inscrire dans la
durée mais on peut faire des choses de
court terme je vais vous donner trois
axes de travail qui seront les extraits
avec nous ont d'abord mieux mutualis des
offres de logement aujourd'hui comme
souvent dans la fonction publique chacun
est dans son silo les fonctionnaires de
tel ministères par versant les
territoriaux les hospitaliers et
personne n'a accès au fond à une offre
de logement qui soit beaucoup plus
mutualisée entre les agents des fichiers
donc je crois effectivement qu'il faut
développer des outils communs pour
pouvoir mieux mutualiser deux on a des
outils qui sont parfois un peu rigides
il y a pas de bail spécifique aux agents
de la fonction publique vous prenez un
logement social le lendemain vous
quittez l'hôpital vous devenez intérêt
mère vous êtes dans votre logement
social et l'employeur c'est pas au fond
si il peut investir pour vous proposer
un logement peut-être qu'il peut y avoir
des réflexions sur ces sujets là et puis
trois il faut produire il faut produire
du logement intermédiaire pour pouvoir
éloger des fonctionnaires il y a déjà
des programmes qui sont lancés ou l'état
léchés on peut contractualiser avec des
opérateurs fabriquer des logements et en
réserver une partie pour loger des
fonctionnaires donc vous voyez c'est
tous les leviers certains de court terme
certains moyen terme certains qui seront
un effort sur la durée pour apporter des
réponses durables réelles concrètes au
fonctionnaires a changé de sujet oui on
va passer un sujet plus politique les
bruits se font de plus en plus intenses
ces derniers jours parlons d'un
remaniement est-ce que on peut continuer
à avancer avec ce même gouvernement ou
est-ce qu'il faut changer les choses
selon vous
qui ont décidé la richesse des sujets
que nous discutons là rémunération des
fonctionnaires secrétaires de mairie
logement on va avancer à l'Assemblée
tout à l'heure sur les questions
d'égalité professionnelle entre les
femmes et zones à fonction publique
est-ce qu'on peut continuer à avancer
bien sûr que oui j'espère humblement
vous en faire la démonstration ce matin
que il y a beaucoup de sujets sur lequel
on bosse et on avance
sur lequel planche aujourd'hui Gérald
Darmanin
il y a des discussions
visiblement la question on n'a pas de
blocage là il y a un travail
préparatoire on veut trouver un
équilibre on veut pouvoir avancer
construire une majorité sur ce texte
avec Gérald Darmanin et en train de
mener ces discussions là c'est le mandat
qu'il a de la première mission avoir du
mal à vous dire président de la
République c'est un sujet important pour
nos concitoyens très important il a été
exprimé pendant l'élection
présidentielle législatives on doit
avancer donc il y a un équilibre à
trouver pour bâtir une majorité autour
de ce texte on a fait la démonstration
qu'on savait bâtir des majorités pas sur
tous les textes il y a eu un conflit
important sur la question des retraites
mais enfin il y a quand même été adopté
dans les conditions qu'on connaît mais
il a été adopté il y a des textes
budgétaires qui ont fait objet de la
49-3 puis à tous les autres textes
ultra majoritaires dans ce qu'un canal
depuis le début du quinquennat c'est
plus d'une trentaine de projets de loi
je crois soixantaine si on compte tous
les textes qui ont été adoptés à
l'Assemblée et au Sénat la
je dis pas que c'est pas nécessaire je
dis que dans la vie moi j'ai une
philosophie qui est de m'inquiéter de ce
qui est entre mes mains à moi alors vous
me pardonnerez cette question là elle
est absolument pas dans mes mains alors
pourquoi est-ce qu'on va y consacrer
toutes nos journées et du jus de cerveau
alors qu'on a quand même du pain sur la
planche sur les sujets qui sont
autrement plus importants voilà c'est
une position qui est assez pragmatique
au fond d'un ministre du gouvernement
que je vous donne ce matin mais vous
êtes aussi un ministre très politique et
on voit que les républicains ont changé
d'attitude depuis la fin de la réforme
des retraites une partie du groupe vous
a aidé au moment des retraites il n'y
ait pas forcément prête aujourd'hui
est-ce que Elisabeth burne est la bonne
personne pour continuer à discuter avec
eux et à négocier avec eux mais
évidemment oui
moi je la soutiens de toutes mes forces
dans ce gouvernement parce qu'elle mène
un travail extrêmement courageux avec de
la clarté avec une vision pour notre
pays avec une feuille de route qui a été
définie avec le président de la
République et elle nous permet d'avancer
qui d'autre qui les avaient devant
feraient mieux que elle aujourd'hui un
ministre droit on sait oui mais vous
savez vous avez avant moi un invité
précédent à Jérôme Bachard qui est
sénateur LR je crois qu'il a dit les
choses avec beaucoup d'honnêteté il a
dit nous on cherche pas une coalition
particulière mais je fais confiance aux
uns et aux autres selon l'intérêt du
pays pour regarder à chaque fois qu'elle
est l'intérêt de la nation et qui permet
d'avancer et je crois que je vous l'ai
dit qui a permis sur de nombreux textes
de pouvoir avancer cette méthode là
c'est la méthode que nous a demandé
d'adopter le pays
ce sont les Français qui ont voté qui
ont donné à la majorité présidentielle
une majorité parfois on a l'impression
un peu de l'oublier une majorité
relative à l'assemb elle oblige à
composer elle oblige à chercher des
équilibres à bâtir des coalitions textes
par textes je crois que c'est à ça
aujourd'hui oui je le crois vous savez
c'était intéressant de voir que dans les
moments peut-être les plus conflictuels
c'était après le 49-3 sur les retraites
tout de suite s'il y avait des textes à
examiner c'est le texte sur le
nucléaires par un petit sujet pour notre
pays il a été adopté avec une large
majorité je crois que c'était le
lendemain était adopté un texte de loi
qui avait été co-construit nupes
Renaissance excusez du peu sur la
question des influenceurs qui est aussi
une question du quotidien des Français
unanimités sur cette expérience donc
vous voyez que en fonction des sujets
peut-être aussi mais bon en fonction de
l'opinion est-ce qu'elle nous demande de
faire des messages clairs qui ont été
adressés pendant les élections
présidentielles législatives bien nous
pourrons avancer vous pensez que le
texte migration une chance d'être voté
oui bien sûr et je crois Gérald Darmanin
fait un excellent travail pour s'en
donner les moyens et bât une majorité
autour de ce qui cherche à la bâtir avec
les républicains cette majorité est-ce
que vous qui vivez personne à gauche
vous le regrettez non bien sûr que donc
je regrette pas il cherche à la bâtir
avec celles et ceux qui sont prêts à
regarder ces questions en face à mettre
aussi parfois
d'idéologie de côté ça peut concerner
tout le monde et trouver des solutions
avec un fil rouge qui suit de
l'efficacité mais la gauche
je souhaite et je l'espère quand on
parle des questions d'immigration de
travail quand on part au fond du réel je
crois que c'est ça qu'il faut faire ces
questions là quand on voit la situation
de gens qui sont sur notre territoire
parfois depuis de nombreuses années qui
sont dans les restaurants dans lequel
nous allons manger dans lequel les
Français vont manger et qui sont dans un
entre deux bien ces questions là je
crois qu'il faut savoir aussi les
adresser avec beaucoup de pragmatisme et
vous voyez que les mesures que la
majorité a mis sur la table puisque
elles ont même était déjà discuté au
Sénat elle recueille une majorité chez
les français quand on les interroge
mesure après mesure à la fois dans notre
capacité à mieux appliquer la loi ces
questions sont connues reconduire faire
appliquer la question des
occultés F des laisser passer
consulaires mais aussi les questions
d'immigration de travail toutes ces
questions sont d'ailleurs assez
largement majoritaire dans l'opinion je
suis certain que les uns et les autres
qui ont un mandat des Français regarde
aussi ces questions là le 21 juin
Stéphane séjourné réunis un certain
nombre de cadres de renaissance pour
discuter de ce sujet là justement quel
partenariat avec les républicains
comment on avance avec eux c'est une
grosse partie du sujet
est-ce que vous ne trouvez pas
aujourd'hui vous qui nez de la gauche
que les toutes tournent autour des
républicains et que ça me déséquilibre
pas ce fameux en même temps la donne
originelle
[Musique]
j'ai exercé ces fonctions tout à fait
mais une réunion politique
de nature strat ique la question
effectivement par cette question de
savoir comment est-ce qu'on continue
d'avancer pas pour la politique
politicienne dans l'intérêt dans
l'intérêt du pays l'ordre du jour c'est
pas
quelle politique avec les républicains
d'ailleurs ça c'est sur les commentaires
qui sont venus s'ajouter à cette réunion
là lors du jour cette réunion c'est une
réunion politique sur notre capacité à
pouvoir avancer mais tant mieux
quelle va être réponse puisque vous
allez être consulté j'imagine qu'elle
est votre réponse est-ce que oui ou non
il faut un accord de coalition avec
l'air mais moi je crois qu'il faut
arrêter de bâtir un discours selon
lequel on voudrait dire on va absorber
les uns et les autres on va élargir la
majorité au sens où les uns les autres
au fond viendrait se soumettre à la
majorité présidentielle je crois que
c'est pas ça la question la question
c'est de pouvoir sur un contenu
programmatique sur des textes concrets
vous savez les grands discours ou les
grands mots ou les questions d'appareil
je crois que ça saoule les Français ils
regardent ça je veux dire chaque jour
d'un peu plus loin encore les questions
qui leur parlent ce sont les questions
concrètes et parfois les questions du
quotidien quand on parle de papier
d'identité quand on parle de nos
capacités dans les mairies assurer sa
république ça ce sont des questions
c'est pour ça qu'il faut qu'on continue
à avancer ça veut pas dire qu'il y a pas
de politique derrière mais on doit la
mettre au service de cette agenda là
qu'un agenda concret de réforme pour
pouvoir permettre de payer d'avancer
merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
Christelle regarder une de la dépêche ce
sont les orages le ciel nous est tombé
sur la tête c'est à la Une de votre
journal merci Christelle merci on passe
au club de territoire